bienvenue chez nous
je sais que cet endroit n'est pas aussi
chaleureux que ce que j'espérais
mais je vais allumer une bougie à la
vanille et tu vas voir ça va réchauffer
l'ambiance
ok on s'en bat
ce manoir est étrange et elle va avoir
besoin de toute la disponible vous
voulez être un héros
je passe j'ai 2000 dollars c'est quoi
l'adresse
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
besoin d'aide
cette maison à la manille de vous jouer
des tours
alors est-ce que tout le monde voit ce
que je vois je le vois moi aussi
soyez prudent dans tous les coins de
cette maison la mort rose
d'autres entités plus puissantes
pourraient bien apparaître non non pas
tant qu'on sera là alors qu'est-ce que
tu comptes faire
sérieux ils sont déjà morts